所有AI工具都在卷谁更快、谁更自动。
但有一个项目偏偏反着来——故意给AI加摩擦、加限制、加规矩。
结果呢？
GitHub上6.7万颗星。
这里是精读AI。
AI世界很吵，每期帮你从全球顶级AI团队的一手文献里，读透一篇最值得读的。
今天我们精读的是Superpowers的设计哲学与实战成本。
上期我们拆了Superpowers的反借口表和双重审查机制——AI说的每句"测试通过了"它都不信。
这期是最后一期。
我们来回答一个根本性的问题：加摩擦这件事，凭什么能赢？
我先讲个类比。
飞行员起飞前有一张检查清单。
哪怕他飞了一万次，每次也必须逐项打钩。
不是因为他不会飞，而是因为出事的代价太高。
Superpowers对AI做的，本质上就是这件事。
它的核心哲学叫"radical discipline over convenience"——纪律优于便利。
别的工具拼命帮你减少步骤，它偏要在关键节点加步骤。
为什么？
因为AI跑得越快，犯错的代价越高。
你让它三秒写完一个模块，它跳过了设计、跳过了测试、跳过了验证。
然后你花三个小时返工。
所以Superpowers的逻辑是：与其事后擦屁股，不如事前多花三十秒确认方向。
这不是反效率，这是真正的效率。
Superpowers的设计哲学可以拆成四个支柱。
第一，纪律优于便利。
它有一条铁律，叫Iron Law：你先写了代码再补测试？
删掉，重来。
不是建议你重来，是强制删掉。
因为先写代码再补测试，测试就变成了走过场。
第二，系统化优于随机试错。
它的调试流程分四个阶段：查根因、找规律、验假设、再动手。
还有一个升级机制——如果连续三次修不好，Agent必须停下来，不许再提修复方案，而是重新审视底层架构。
官方数据说，系统化调试的一次修复成功率是百分之95，耗时15到30分钟。
随机试错呢？
成功率百分之40，耗时两到三个小时。
第三，证据优于声明。
AI说"我改好了"，不算数。
必须拿出验证证据。
收到代码审查意见后，禁止说"你说得对！
好建议！
"这种表演性回复，必须用技术事实来回应。
第四，也是最有意思的一点：把AI当准人类来管理。
这里要停一下。
什么叫"准人类"？
你可以想象你带了一个天才新员工。
智商极高，学什么都快，但没耐心、爱走捷径、还特别会找借口。
你不能用编程语言给他下指令，你得用管理学和心理学。
Superpowers的说服力文档里有一句话：LLM对人类有效的说服技巧同样有效，因为它就是从人类文本中训练出来的。
所以你不是在"编程"AI，你是在"管理"AI。
这是一个全新的视角。
说完哲学，我们看实证。
Superpowers不是一拍脑袋定出来的规则集。
它的每一次版本迭代，都来自真实观察。
3.2版，加了命名空间标准化——因为发现Agent被不一致的技能引用搞糊涂了。
3.2.2版，强化了反借口机制——因为发现Agent嘴上答应用技能，实际偷偷跳过。
4.0版，加了双阶段代码审查——因为发现单人审查总是漏掉规格问题。
4.3版，给头脑风暴阶段加了硬门禁——因为模型总跳过设计，直接冲去写代码。
每一条规则背后，都有一个真实的翻车案例。
这不是理论框架，这是临床医学——观察症状、开药、观察疗效、调整处方。
再看成本。
一个完整的Superpowers工作流，包含TDD、双阶段审查、任务追踪，实现一个简单的两函数数学库，总API成本是4.67美元。
其中主协调器4.09美元，每个子Agent调用只要7到9美分。
而且安装只要30秒。
两条命令，不需要API密钥，不需要额外基础设施。
技能装好之后自动触发，你该怎么用Claude Code就怎么用。
三期读完，我们回到最开始的问题：AI越来越强，我们到底应该怎么用它？
Superpowers给出的答案是：AI越强大，纪律越重要。
让AI变慢一点、想多一点，比让它跑得更快更有价值。
这不只是一套工具的设计哲学。
这是一个信号：未来管理AI的方式，可能比AI本身更重要。
给你一个马上能用的行动建议：给你的AI助手设一条硬规则——任何任务开始前，必须先输出方案和检查清单，得到你的确认后才能动手。
哪怕只是改一行配置文件。
AI世界很吵，精读一篇，胜过刷一百条。
我们下期再见。